at being 10 o'clock good morning
everybody and I'd like to open the
public hearing on HB 30.
um allowing a county to exempt its chief
administrative officer from compulsory
participation in the retirement system
excuse me and I would like to welcome
representative Aaron
welcome to executive departments and
administration
thank you so much Mr chair good morning
committee I'm so happy to be here and uh
see so many new faces on this committee
so I'm here today to present uh hb30
and this bill allows the County
Commissioners to exempt the County chief
administrative officer from compulsory
membership in the State Retirement
System
if you recall some of you who are here
this bill came to the house in the form
of HB 1561 and HB 141 in 2020 and 2021
respectively
both times they passed this committee
and were subsequently added to the
Omnibus bills that got tabled during
covet
so it's time that we get this issue
settled and passed
there's no need for our County managers
to be compelled to participate in the
state retirement system especially if
they already have retirement plans
elsewhere
most of them have come up through the
system and have already vested in group
one and therefore very likely to stay in
the retirement system but some may have
an exemption exception
and we should give them the right to
choose
the financial impact to the state
retirement system is nil as a as we have
been shown in the fiscal impact section
of the bill
where um
they the New Hampshire retirement system
folks stated that the bill would have an
indeterminable impact on County
expenditures in fiscal year 2026 as the
rates have already been set for fiscal
year 2024 and fiscal year 2025 and the
system also states that the impact would
only affect up to 10 nhrs members and
would have a small impact less than 0.1
percent on the entire payroll from which
um given the history of this legislation
and the support that this committee has
given this legislation
I hope that we can pass this through the
committee again get it through the house
and hope for a better outcome
and that's really all I have to say in
introducing this bill
thank you very much are you taking
questions sure
yes representative O'Brien thank you Mr
chair
um representative are you familiar I
think it's RSA 100a
which basically envelops or Embraces the
retirement system that in the example a
community cannot back out
of the retirement system unless they
meet all liability uh unfunded liability
and would that apply in the case that
you're presenting today
I actually am not sure
um I would imagine well perhaps maybe
I'll let you off the hook maybe somebody
that would testify and clean that up
well I do know that the this would bring
it in line to how we operate with the
municipalities too I think they also
seeing none thank you very much
appreciate it
and I would like to welcome
good morning chair members of the
committee I'm Carol Maguire representing
Merrimack District 27 which is the towns
of Allenstown Dunbarton Epsom and
Hooksett
new district and I'm in support of house
bill 30.
one thing that happened
recently in Merrimack County is that we
found our County Corrections director to
be interested and qualified in being the
chief executive
but since he had spent his career in
group two he was not the least bit
interested in taking contributing to a
group one pension
for some few years that would if
anything dilute his benefits
the way the system is set up
if you're in group two for most of your
career and you have a small amount of
group one
it
not only it means you get a tiny amount
of Social Security which is then docked
and your your pension is less because
the factors for between group one and
group two are different
so
they the county was looking for a way to
not have this person be in the
retirement system
I don't know exactly what they did I
think they
appointed him to a fixed term which is
generally optional
but
that is a problem that may come up again
if someone who is
under consideration for the county
executive has a group two background
there this isn't going to be favorable
other County Executives some of them as
representative O'Brien said come up
through the
state and County governments and they're
fine with staying in the retirement
system but others
travel around they come from out of
state they come from private or Private
Industry
and being in
the retirement system for a short period
of time
at the end of your career is not really
useful and this applies to other defined
benefit pensions as well because you're
only working for a few years you don't
have time to build build up credit and
so they don't want to be in
um
in the system because if you stay there
for five years and then you finish your
term and go on
you get back your contributions plus a
nominal
return whereas if you had put that money
into a
another type of retirement benefit you
would be much better off you also lose
the employer contributions
and
the
if the committee is concerned about
um
the unfunded liability on due on this
position
we could add in that they paid the
unfunded portion as if it were in the
retirement system they should but that's
a
a secondary effect
there there are there is only one chief
executive Per County
there are more City
managers and so forth that are allowed
to be Exempted from this from the
retirement system and they don't pay
into the uh
um toward the unfunded liability
so I in a matter of equity I think we
should not do that
and I'll be glad to answer the questions
I I can
thank you representative McGuire any
questions yes representative O'Brien
thank you Mr chair
um
representative McGuire I'm going to pick
at your expertise that I deeply respect
here on the matter you're almost as good
as me with the pension system almost
but what I'm kind of concerned with part
of the safeguards is we have uh RSA 100a
I and I think you're familiar with that
and so much once you say you could want
to belong to the system you're in the
particular system and we don't really
want communities to back out of it you
know uh wants them to stay invested and
to grow and what does not are we gonna
start I understand it's only 30 people
and I think about 10 people 10 people
the numbers are relatively small and I
realize that but I'm just afraid of the
slippery slope so can you uh smooth me
over a little bit well representative
O'Brien right now
the
city managers and so forth can be
Exempted
if which is a larger group than County
executives
unclassified state employees can be
Exempted people who are appointed to
fixed term positions are can be Exempted
the membership of the retirement system
is optional for a
a group of types of positions that are
likely to be
late career
positions and for limited times and also
oddly enough for elected officials
so your county sheriff is probably a
member of the retirement system because
he would most likely have come up
through
um
through the police or Corrections office
however
your county attorney
may or may not be in the system
depending on whether he was say the
Concord city prosecutor before he got
elected or he was in private uh had a
private business
you know and it's it's up to the elected
official
and so adding the County chief executive
officer
simply makes the statute more consistent
and on who can be optionally in the
system
and I thank you for the clarity thank
you Mr chair
thank you Mr chairman so representative
McGuire if you recall uh a number of
years ago we changed the statute and the
arrangement with the retirement system
with regard to people coming in from out
of state and buying into the system
right because it was determined that in
point of fact this did not uh this was
not in equity with regard to the people
who had come up and been part of the
system for years and it was harmful to
determined to be harmful to the system
so we stopped that people could no
longer come in from out of state and we
do it was referenced in the earlier
testimony uh that very often County
Executives in this category uh are
coming in from out of state
and it would there uh would would that
be an analogous situation with regard to
the to the being overall detrimental to
the system
if you know I don't believe it's exactly
analogous it's more a matter of being
fair to the individuals involved
the system is so minimal that
it's not going to matter but considering
that other equivalent positions have
optional membership this just adds
another another position like that
representative Fitzpatrick is more of an
expert on this than I am but uh
follow-up so uh in other words it's it's
it's the same principle in one respect
but because the numbers in comparison
with people coming in from out of state
across the Spectrum their numbers would
be considerable whereas these numbers
are so small that it really the impact
is effectively now well it's also that
the people coming from out of state as
police officers or teachers or whatever
would be
thinking about buying their entire
service
in this case someone is saying well I
want to stop whatever service I had
prior to starting this job and I'll and
I'll deal with my with this job
differently
any other questions
yes representative
thank you Mr chair
um I'm sure that you and I are both
aware of
the past history
of this field particularly in this
committee it has technically passed Edna
twice and gone through the house and
been accepted but then faltered in the
senate for some reason I believe in both
cases it was endorsed by our counterpart
in the Senate Edna and I was curious if
you have an inkling as to why the Senate
has turned this down if they if we need
some sort of fix to it to get through
that hurt
um
I didn't study the report but
in both cases
um it was it wasn't voted down it was
tabled
in one case it was tabled during covid
during 2020 when a great many worthwhile
bills were tabled and died in both the
house and the Senate
the other one was tabled
with the Senate Edna recommendation of
what to pass and I don't know how how
that happened but I think we should look
into it
um I will point out uh the last one the
one that I actually amended to change to
this same bill basically
ought to pass in the Senate failed 11 to
12 and then they laid it on the table so
there obviously were some objections I
didn't know if you had insight into what
those were thank you I'm afraid I I
don't know how the Senate works
representative O'Brien
thank you um representative McGuire uh
if you be so kind
um
personally I'm against double dipping
and different things like that so if
this bill passes which it has had the
history in the past
uh is that person once they went to this
new system that is proposed are they
retired and then able to collect their
they would be in this if they had worked
in the new and the New Hampshire
retirement system up until this point
they would be as eligible to retire as
your example your county sheriff is it's
optional and so he he could in fact
choose to retire collect this pension
and collect his pay as the county
sheriff
and that is a
a factor in the retirement system that
exists for all those people who are
Exempted and I believe all pretty much
all County Sheriffs are retired and
collecting a pay a paycheck
but
that's a broader issue than this one
person
thank you representative thank you Mr
chair representative true
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question I
realize basically the only change is
you're adding counties they are adding
counties along with municipalities
and I know it's it's already in the uh
already in the RSA but
could you explain starting maybe it
would line six
because it's it's talking about RSA 100
that has been mentioned before
maybe just explain to me
um what's going on there
so that if somebody asked me I could at
least make it and tell them what's going
on starting on line six
talks about
uh
that is a transition Clause from when
the retirement system was initiated in
the 1960s so it's really kind of there
as at least that's the way I read it
seeing no one thank you representative
McGuire okay thank you and I will uh
welcome our distinguished friend from
the nhrs uh Marty Carlin to this
thank you Mr chair for the record uh
Marty Carlin uh representing the New
Hampshire retirement system uh nhrs
doesn't have a position on this bill we
see it as a policy question for the
legislature as planned sponsor
essentially is this change necessary to
improve the the quality and quantity of
candidates for these County
Administrator positions and keep people
in it so we don't have a position on the
bill I signed up just for informational
purposes to give a little history on the
current exemption optional exemption for
municipal managers and and some other
general information and then take any
questions you may have
um the exemption in a22 for uh Municipal
uh
chief administrative officers was put
into the statute back in the early 70s
which is a bit before my time so I'm not
sure of the rationale but it's been
there for many many years and this
allows upon hiring
um the governing body to choose to
exempt their that position from nhrs
it's it's tied for the initial higher
you can't retro you know somebody
couldn't be in for five years and then
the they could become Exempted after
that and that same language carries over
with the inclusion of County
administrators
as other people have said this is
there's ten counties so these are 10
positions uh out of over 24
000 contributing member positions and a
payroll of around a billion and a half
so so the um you know the the actuary
determined that you know it would be an
indeterminably small
um you know cost going forward if all of
them were Exempted
um currently the as again alluded to
um by by a prior speaker there is
another way to exempt these positions
currently which is uh the the county
governing body would have would hire
them and appoint them for a fixed term
um and they during which they could only
be removed for cause not as an at-will
employee like most employees are uh
based We Believe Three Counties have
done that currently with their existing
administrators
um so so that you know they but um
you know that that's just another way to
do this so uh be glad to answer any
questions any of the members may have
about this and uh
actually one one last thing too the the
question about line six uh from one of
the Reps that that's a provision that
this overall provision if an if a full
participate If an employer opts to join
the retirement system on Moss for all of
its employees that language about buying
time allows members who are working for
that Community before they joined nhrs
up to a year to buy their past
experience with that town as nhrs
service so it's nothing to do with um
what what's in front of you today the
any questions
yes representative shewitt
thank you thank you for taking my
question Mr Carlin uh you talked about
um I guess you'd call it a workaround uh
if a county appoints their administrator
for a fixed term
uh would they then be allowed to do that
for an additional fixed term is there
any limitation to that no there's no
limit on fixed term appointments many
Commissioners who've served the state a
long time it's a similar concept to that
thank you
yes representative O'Brien thank you uh
Mr chair and uh Mr Collins
this probably has very little impact on
the uaal than not to be of concern
any any impact is is you know of some
level of concern but this is a de
minimis
representative true
thank you Mr Chen thank you for taking
my question
you would mentioned that some counties
uh
have already doing this that the work
around with a fixed term
so if this weren't to pass
there is still the option there's
there's still the paid a way for
counties to
to offer this to their executives
I
I'm not I'm looking over here and I'm
going to start talking and attorney
Kavanaugh who's from nhrs and is joining
me to testify on the last bill
um I think once their fixed term is over
and they're rehired that would be the
point at which they could exempt them or
no right
would you like to come up to the
um
so this is the
thing that applies to officials
appointed to a fixed term which is an
historical phrase that comes from the
old state plan prior to 1967. however
and those are typically
um top level Executives at the division
directors and the like that are
appointed pursuant to a statute as
nominated by the governor approved by
the executive Council can only be
removed from cause under RSA 5 after a
hearing
technically the law also applies to
political subdivisions such as the
county they don't have statutes that
apply fixed terms or provide for for
cause hearings and so to parallel what
the statutes that apply to state
uh positions we have had a long-standing
administrative interpretation that to be
appointed for a fixed term you have to
have in your contract a provision that
says you can only be removed for cause
and there are three counties that have
done that with their County
administrators but that can also you
know for personnel and other reasons not
be desirable you know other counties may
say we'd rather have someone at will and
not have to uh have a foreclosed
provision by passing this bill you would
allow them to exempt to people without
having that restriction that's currently
representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman and which three
counties are those
um
so we're only talking 10 people
so just the fact that we're talking such
a small amount of people that would mean
that the impact on the unfunded
liability is pretty small is that not
true that is true
any other questions
I just have one on that same vein excuse
me
ten it affects 10 people but three of
them are effectively not in the
retirement system at the present moment
already so really in our present State
it's seven people
that that this would impact at least in
the immediacy OR to say that the the
seven positions for when they hire new
County administrators in those counties
they wouldn't all be converted under
this law because it does it at point of
higher so right you know that could be
years from now they're happy with the
folks they have
yeah
all right thank you gentlemen very much
was anybody else interested in
if not I will close the hearing on hb30
without objection we'll move into
do I have a motion from the committee
yes
ought to pass on House Bill 30.
representative Grady motion sought to
pass on HP 30 do I have a second second
uh representative Ryan seconds
um representative Grady would you like
to speak to your motion
thank you um having heard this bill
before and um having
um agreed with it in the past and
putting
um counties on parity with
municipalities or all reasons why I
think this committee should support the
auto pass motion
thank you representative Brian would you
like to speak to your second
yes
thank you Mr chair uh as you have
witnessed I asked some questions I had
them all very well answered and my
concerns with the uaal seems to be
extremely minimal so therefore I don't
see this as a major impact and and
pretty much keeps the system as we know
it in operating so I am going to offer
my support but this thank you
anyone else
representative abstractric and then
representative true is it appropriate to
just uh explain why I support something
um what was not mentioned
and something which I believe is in the
public interest is that this will expand
the amount of applicants
that the County Commissioners will have
to choose from
there's a Cadre of city and county
managers in the country I'm a member of
that organization the international City
County Managers Association
and uh about half of us stay in the
states that were that we start in and
we're always in the retirement system
but there's another half out there that
moves from state to a state kind of like
you know Nomads or uh uh I used to I
used to think I was a a a a Rowan
who wasn't working for a show a Shogun
but anyway
uh this will allow people who are well
some well myself I chose to go from
state to state and to be in what's known
as the icma
retirement corporation which is a 401a
program
and uh I wouldn't have come to I
wouldn't even apply to the city of
Rochester
if if cities weren't allowed to do this
because I was like 60 and I was I didn't
have time to even start a a brand new uh
retirement system so what the the bottom
line public benefit
is that it will increase the
pool of candidates for your county when
they're choosing a chief executive
officer that's it and that may a larger
pool may or may not allow to have a a
I'm thank you for this opportunity thank
you representative true
a question of the chair
does is this retroactive or is this only
no
sorry I'm
no it's not
uh yes representative
thank you Mr chair um I would just sort
of echo what representative Fitzpatrick
was saying as you've all heard Merrimack
County is one of the counties that is
currently using this workaround and it's
because our commissioners definitely
felt that the head of our Corrections at
the time was very familiar with the
county and its operations and an ideal
candidate but he was hesitant to accept
the appointment because of jeopardizing
his group to pension so it kind of you
have to measure you know what's what's
best for your county
and that he obviously ended up since
this the previous Bill did fail he ended
up approaching them to find another way
and they came up with with the work
around so it does in effect limit the
ability to hire someone that you feel is
ideal for the physician in some cases
oh representative Schmidt
um thank you Mr chairman well both
Representatives short and representative
Fitzpatrick remarks uh lead me to point
out that it might not be just a question
of expanding the pool but you might have
in your own County a specific individual
candidate
available who's outstanding that you
want that person and this could be the
key to that person being interested in
taking the job so it's not just a bigger
pool but you could be for a specific
individual that you specifically want so
this is a kind of a no-lose situation in
my opinion thank you thank you
seeing no one I will ask the clerk to
call the roll
motion for House Bill 30 is ought to
pass I'm taking vote role
representative Simon yes representative
leikis yes
representative Bailey yes
representative santoso yes
representative true yes
representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes
the clerk votes yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuette yes representative O'Brien
yes representative Wilhelm yes
representative Davis
yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
and
oh I'm sorry I didn't know you were
voting representative I mean Madam chair
yes
yes whether or not I'm testifying at the
hearing I'm still a member of the
committee and allowed to vote on the
bill okay and it applies to everyone
else on the committee as well all right
I'm sorry thank you
hey you're getting new experiences
that's my fault I gave him the wrong
and with the vote I move the consent
that would be put on the consent
calendar okay the vote the vote being 18
to zero the motion passes
okay seeing none we'll put this one on
and this committee is just too efficient
we have eight minutes before the next
hearing
all right we're I'm opening the public
hearing on House Bill 183
thank you I apologize oh
I apologize folks let me I apologize and
start over again thank you
representative uh Madam chair uh through
you to my esteemed colleagues of the
general court my name is Bill Boyd I'm a
representative from Hillsborough County
District 12 representing the town of
Merrimack and I'm here to testify in
support of House Bill 183 which seeks to
exempt
part-time firefighters from the pension
system as it relates to teaching
opportunities at the fire academy
in 2022 there was an ad hoc committee
involving fire and EMS retention
Recruitment and Retention that did a
comprehensive 23-page report talking
about the State of Affairs as it relates
to firing EMS Recruitment there were 21
state level recommendations 16 local
recommendations and three General
recommendations that they made in that
report two of the recommendations
deck caught the prime sponsor's
attention representative wolf was
recommendation number nine which would
be increasing the number of available
training opportunities throughout the
state thereby increasing the number of
trained individuals and reducing travel
time for students and then
recommendation 21 which amplifies the
bill in question today support
legislation that would allow the New
Hampshire retirement system retirees to
work as on-call firefighters and
Emergency Medical Service Providers
emergency situations without those hours
counting towards the annual hour
limitation for time employees and that's
what this bill seeks to accomplish it
seeks to add retired firefighters to the
bill exempting them for their annual
hour limitations so they can go to
Concord they could go to Bethlehem and
actually pass along their years of
experience the institutional knowledge
that they've Acquired and passing it
along to the student the men and women
that are choosing a career as First
Responders in this state not just the
the actual academic component but
actually getting you know real life
experiences from from some of the men
and women right now and those that have
retired that are positioned to to talk
about their experiences and pastless
experiences along to them
right now in New Hampshire Recruitment
and Retention is a widespread problem
especially in some of our our in our
rural communities where they rely
heavily and volunteer on on-call uh
responders it's been very difficult to
get those types of individuals to step
up in their local community to assist at
that particular level the only way that
you can increase
potentially the level of First
Responders in our state is to increase
the number of people that that are
working at the at the Academy
so that's the that's really the the the
basic crust of of the bill the one thing
that I have handed around for the
Committees
um consideration is
including the department of police
standards and training
something that when representative wolf
had put his bill together I had
suggested that maybe we need to include
the police standards division as well as
a part as a part of the conversation
again with our with with our men in blue
putting you know having a lot of
experience of working on the streets
um not just with you know crime fighting
but also the community policing piece
which our state takes a lot of pride in
doing again it's that kind of acquired
knowledge that they can pass on to
Future men and women seeking a career in
law enforcement again not the academic
piece but also learning from people from
men and women that have actually been on
the streets
um working with people and fighting
crime so that's the extent of my
presentation
um thank you very much Madam chair and
to the steam colleagues for listening to
me and I certainly would Avail myself to
questions
thank you very much representative
representative O'Brien has a question
thank you madam chair uh representative
thank you for taking my question uh
representative Boyd are you familiar
with actually how many hours that a
retired employee
can work
I apologize 25 hours 25 hours okay uh
could not not be handled with an
adjustable block as far as the
scheduling for some of the training
instead of changing a state law
so that the short answer to your
question is probably yes
I don't know the larger any answer to
the question representative O'Brien
because unlike you I I did not put on
the uniform and I know you did so
obviously your institutional knowledge
probably comes into play as it relates
to this and I think your perspective
could be valuable in that regard I would
love in that job position but I think I
feel glad to have a lot of the stuff I
learned so thank you it's a fair
question I just I don't have an
appropriate answer representative thank
you thank you
yep
representative goalie and are you
gentlemen okay thank you
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
if
I guess I'm not sure if you're the right
person to answer or someone from
um The Academy but if there is a
staffing issue
is it only in part-time employment or
should we be if there's truly a staffing
issue in getting these programs
implemented should we be looking more at
hiring full-time employees instead of
filling voids with part-time I mean
that's I mean that's that's certainly a
fair comment representative you know not
knowing the actual day-to-day operations
of of both the and I'm going to use this
colloquially the police academy and the
fire academy not knowing what what their
day-to-day roles are I think the concern
that you raise is certainly certainly a
valid one if it is indeed true I just I
can't speak to it because I honestly
don't know
follow-up we do have someone from the
police and the fire signed up to speak
and I agree they would probably be the
best person to answer that kind of
question
and I just am asking because my concerns
are as we talk about
retirees filling voids in part-time
positions wouldn't you agree we could
open up a can of worms here because
we've gone from just the fire academy
now to the police academy and what's
going to be the next group coming in
here looking to fill that void and get
an exemption from the number of hours
worked for this for the retirement
system again it's it's a fair concern I
I wouldn't dismiss it
all right any other questions for the
representative
all right seeing none thank you very
much to the committee and you madam
chair thank you very much and I'd like
to call Mr Jeffrey Phillips who I
believe is with the fire academy
foreign
good morning Madam chair and the rest of
the committee I thank you for this
opportunity to speak to you my name is
Jeffrey Phillips I'm the assistant
director at the division of fire stands
as a training and Emergency Medical
Services which operates the fire academy
currently right now I've worked for the
division for over 20 years and I would
say currently right now the demand for
training uh firing EMS in the state of
New Hampshire is as high as it possibly
can be as representative
um Boyd spoke there was a recruitment
and retention committee report and uh
study done
um and essentially this this is a domino
effect for us the locals continue to
have struggles getting uh fire and EMS
professionals
um which reduces because their uh
Staffing is our main source of
instructors as of right now to
representative goalie we have no
full-time uh dedicated instructors that
their sole job is to perform education
we have 187 part-time uh currently
part-time instructors approximately 25
percent of those instructors are
retirees we rely heavily on these
individuals
um one answer that I can't do in regards
to representative O'Brien's comment in
regards to it's it comes I believe to in
like an average of 25 hours a week I
think it's like a 1300 hour cap per year
um but it used to be per employer right
now it's cumulative for all employers so
we do not have visibility on the number
of hours our retirees work for other
agencies but if you have a person that
works for the Concord the Goffstown Fire
Department or the Bethlehem fire
department
um their hours are also added to
um the ones that they work at the fire
academy for teaching we do have several
employees that continue to work multiple
hours for multiple agencies that were
responding on fire and EMS calls and
they really are limited in the number of
hours that they can work for us in
regards to scheduling and representative
O'Brien's comment
um we try to do uh as creative
scheduling as possible to uh be able to
perform the trainings that we do however
due to the vast majority of the
trainings that we do
um throughout the state uh we do
trainings in Concord we do trainings at
Bethlehem but those are actually limited
most of our trainings are spread out
through through the entire state so
we're sending people to co-work to Keene
to Portsmouth throughout the entire
state to run all of our programs and
trying to get these schedules to work
with our instructors as but as well at
least with our students schedules as
well is extremely difficult
um as of right now
um we Pro we have I think 27 sort of
nationally certificate nationally
accredited certification programs and
hundreds of continuing education
programs that we offer we don't have one
discipline where we have a sufficient
amount of instructors to be able to
offer these programs uh to the demand
that we have
um
while we don't exactly know the impact
of this we know for sure there would be
retirees that would be able to teach
additional hours for us and at this
point right now we're just continuously
looking for high quality candidates
retirees they have 15 to 20 years of
extremely valuable experience for us to
be able to tap into and to teach these
new men and women come in to fire an EMS
and it would be a great resource for us
to continue to use
can answer any questions
thank you are there other questions
represent Gould
thank you madam chair my cousin Vicki
Blanchard I spoke to her the other night
at from the state you probably know her
I know her very well and she and Chris
were getting ready to go to Orlando
Chris is doing the conference but she
assured me that
exactly what you said that the need for
the retirees the need for the
flexibility is very important at the
Academy and that she felt this would
help a great deal
so yep and we would agree I think it
definitely would help us I mean
we at the fire academy and I won't speak
for director skippa at the police
academy but um to be able to educate
people and fire an EMS uh the experience
is the key so we're looking for those
men and women that have the experience
to be able to bring to us so they can
teach
um and this is this is just one this is
not a solve for our Recruitment and
Retention issues at the Academy and
stuff like that but it would be a
potential help
thank you other questions yes represent
goalie
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking the question
he stated that
most of the instructors or if not all
are part-time
I guess my question goes to have you or
even
approached the ability of
going to some full-time staff
for outreach and for instructing So
currently we have had that those
conversations internally through the
budget process at this time it has been
more of a
um
I want to I guess a fight financial
decision that we have not gone in that
direction uh this current state of the
fire and EMS fund
um is not performing to the point where
because that that appears that
is an Avenue to go to get some full-time
instructors on there and get them into
the positions
um you know to be continued to keep have
some continuity in the programs if you
have some on staff instructors that are
there all the time nope and I would
agree with the representative's comments
okay representative O'Brien
thank you Chief you mentioned um
it's a cumulative effect in this and I
don't really understand it because I
never been in that type of situation to
become familiar but would that not be
the fixed if that were to be a limited
are you prepared to answer or do you
want to refer to uh uh
future witness and may bring more better
testimony on that because if it goes
with the cumulative effect I can see
where it compresses at 25 hours you
eliminate that that might eliminate your
problem
that would that would be my
understanding so it I'm not sure when
the legislation changed at one point it
used to be on a per employer basis and
then at one point over the I believe the
last 10 15 years it had changed to
change to a cumulative so all employers
were that had to be under the 1300 hours
if that cumulative
um
was not the case I would say and it
would be accomplishing relatively the
same thing that this bill would do
because the hours taught for the fire
academy would be limited at 25
um the Affordable Care Act limits us to
29 and a half so I mean from our
perspective I believe that would it
thank you madam chair my question being
from a firefighter family is the fire
academy can you give us some metrics
with regard to is are these firefighters
that are coming on to the force that
attend the fire academy are the is it
renewal training is it annual is it you
know
how many go through there can you give
us some metrics yep um so in the state
of New Hampshire
um there for there there's really
there's two kind of uh tracks there's a
career firefighter which has
certification requirements within the
first year of their employment they have
to go through the initial firefighter
one which is about uh just under 200
hours in firefighter 2 which is about 70
hours they have to have that within
their first year of employment and then
you have the call volunteer part-time uh
staff where there is no legislative
requirement of any training however best
practices throughout the entire State
most Fire Chiefs want to ensure that
these folks have the knowledge and
training to be able to go into a burning
building or deal with motor vehicle
accidents propane emergencies Hazmat
incidents so they really before they put
them into those situations they require
them to go through training so it's
really been a little bit of both we do
have some people that come out of the
city of Manchester that's not on a fire
department that have no connection to
the fire service and go through the
training with no experience but I would
say the vast majority of our students
that go through fire one and fire two
are on a small local department
and they're really kind of waiting to
get to training to be a full member of
the department
for those numbers we do about 200 to 250
fire one of fires two students but
that's just one program that we offer we
have like I said we have multiple other
certification programs that we offer
other questions
um
well oh yes representative Schmidt thank
you you're speaking yourself
thank you madam chair so did I
understand you correctly that there is
no State statutory requirement for
you said call Firefighters that's the
same as a volunteer you are correct
is it yeah uh local control
is that is that responsible on the
state's part to let somebody go into a
situation
with no training
um there's no State mandate um I will
say best practice uh if you talk to
probably any fires uh Chief in the state
of New Hampshire is those individuals
that have not had the training are
limited in regards to what they can do
most of them are support roles that you
know I mean they could pick up a ladder
move a ladder but they would probably
not be put in a hazardous environment on
a kind of a global level
anyone else here
I had a question it
if you're
hiring part-time people isn't the main
difference in budget the fact that you
don't have to contribute to the uh
retirement system for those people
uh the two main differences would be the
retirement system contribution the
health insurance contribution
thank you very much yep all right anyone
else
thank you very much thank you
good morning Madam chair good morning uh
honorable members of the committee uh my
name is John skippa I'm the director of
New Hampshire police standards and
training and I appreciate your time
today uh to allow me to speak uh I was
actually contacted by director Justin
cutting who's uh my my peer at the fire
academy uh just to pass along that this
bill was being
introduced and and uh suggested that uh
we might have uh some interest in seeing
this move forward uh to that end uh much
like uh assistant director who just
spoke uh at the on the police side of
things we're experiencing the same kind
of uh training issues uh
there are some differences between our
two organizations between the fire
academy and the police academy
presently the police centers and
training council is responsible for
certifying and training every single law
enforcement officer in the state of New
Hampshire which is uh somewhat different
than uh the the fire side of the house
where there is a volunteer track
not only do we uh represent the sole
source of recruit training for every one
of those officers but we are also the
primary uh trainer for in-service
programs uh in-service training hours
are required as part of
the officers being able to maintain
their certification or license to work
annually
uh
we are looking anecdotally at about a 20
percent reduction in uh or a 20 vacancy
rate if you will anecdotally across the
state of New Hampshire with regard to
law enforcement positions you can look
at the newspaper or the news and see
this uh is not just a problem here in
New Hampshire but it is a problem
Nationwide
as a law enforcement leader and speaking
with my fellow
leaders we don't know if there is uh if
this is an anomaly that we're just kind
of seeing or whether this is going to be
a long trending issue
to that end police standards and
training is responsible for over 4 000
certified officers
as of this year 2023 we have also been
given new challenges to meet these
challenges came from uh recommendations
set forth by the liac commission and put
into play by the governor's executive
order
and that increased the amount of
training that we had to provide at a
recruit level and it has also increased
the mandatory in-service training hours
for in-service officers from eight hours
up to 24 hours
and that will be instituted over a
three-year period of time and we're in
our first year now moving that forward
on top of that uh New Hampshire police
standards and training now has the
conduct Review Committee uh that is
responsible for uh reviewing and
investigating any uh allegation of
police misconduct which is a brand new
challenge that police standards and
with that particular responsibility it
is imperative that we're able to retain
some folks that have a tremendous amount
of experience in New Hampshire law
enforcement that have held rank that
have been in the business for a long
time have level heads and can understand
the nuances of investigating uh police
officers
we can't find that kind of talent
in a full-time capacity unless we try to
hire people who are coming from other
states and it would be really nice to be
able to retain New Hampshire police
Executives to take on not only the the
conduct review role but really pass
along their knowledge that they have
acquired over their career and for all
of those reasons
we would really ask that if this if this
bill were to go forward for further
consideration that uh full-time police
officers working hours at the police
academy would be included or amended to
this bill
uh anecdotally uh we have 12 full-time
trainers and we have three part-time
trainers to handle uh the the
responsibilities that that our agency
oversees
I I thank you for your time and I stand
ready for any questions
thank you are there questions
representative Schmidt
thank you ma'am Cher thank you for being
here sir uh could you spell your last
name uh I I didn't quite catch it oh
absolutely uh it is
s-c-i-p-p-a oh no ER
much like uh all right we all want to
other questions
representative O'Brien thank you madam
chair if you'll indulge me just to uh
uh some write in my notes you stated how
many full-time and how many part-time I
I just would like those numbers reviewed
the uh training specialist yes yes so we
we presently have uh 12 full-time
training specialists and we have three
follow up
comparatively you know I don't want a
cat and dog issue you know with the
police and fire I understand I've lived
it for 35 years but the thing is
uh but the thing is is it equal to the
fire academy or do you have more
full-time capabilities
so it's uh and I uh it's a wonderful
question sir and I I uh absolutely share
uh your your position on this uh Justin
cutting my my uh compatriot over at the
fire academy and I we enjoy a tremendous
relationship but we do work uh very well
together and it's it's really an apple
and an orange because the the fire
academy and EMS academy uh they they
really uh as as the assistant director
spoke to there's two different tracks
for the fire service and uh I you know
I'm gonna speak out of school here I
know the assistant director could speak
more clearly in this but there's there's
much more in the way of volunteer
firefighters and EMS providers uh than
there are there's no such thing as a
volunteer police officer they have to
have a certification to do that
um we you know we certainly
um I I
I I think that uh from our perspective
and it's it's important one of the
recommendations that came forward and
that we're introducing is to introduce a
whole lot more scenario Based training
scenario-based training is the best way
to teach adults uh particularly uh to
respond to Dynamic situations you need a
lot of instructors for that you need
actors you need evaluators you need
safety officers uh to over just to
oversee it make sure that we don't
introduce a live weapon or have an
injury these are very Dynamic situations
sometimes
so just the number of uh instructors the
the amount of help we need to create a
meaningful scenario training event uh is
is pretty significant but we don't need
those people all the time we just need
them when we're doing the scenario
training we run four full-time academies
a year we run uh two Corrections
academies a year and we run one to two
part-time police academies a year so we
we are constantly uh moving people
through that facility for those
different levels of training and I don't
know if that that is uh responding to
your question no you didn't thank you
very much for your reply thank you sir
okay representative gerhardt
thank you madam chair thank you taking
my question the 20 vacancy was that
correct that anecdotally yes yeah so the
main reason would be physical fitness
issues I remember reading about the
Department of Corrections had issues
they wanted to lower the physical
standards is that part of the issue
what's going on
so I I this is a wonderful question and
I think it speaks more broadly right in
our country right now but um there's a
lot of people who uh considered entering
law enforcement as a profession and and
simply because of
um the landscape right now I think
there's just a lot of people who are uh
looking to other other directions I
think on top of that uh we are seeing a
lot of uh not a lot but we are seeing a
consistent number of New Hampshire law
enforcement officers that may have five
or ten years into the business and
they're stepping away to go to the
private sector again for those same
reasons it's it has just gotten uh
dramatically more
dangerous uh there is a lot less I think
a feeling of support by uh
communities and and Society in general
and and uh it really is uh I've been at
this for almost 40 years and I've never
seen it this way before
it's an interesting question thank you
sir I hope I answered it yeah follow up
thank you madam chair appreciate it just
side related note would there I know you
kind of does it doesn't seem very
popular but would there be an
a possibility for some sort of auxiliary
police force only to encourage more
people to participate in said occupation
to I know there was some that there's
some desire it's kind of unrelated but
some desire to have social workers go
out and so forth is that being thought
of or I mean we could take this off I
don't want to get this yet I'd be happy
to talk with you offline but just just
to give you uh an idea we do run a
part-time police academy and uh you know
there's certain parts of our state that
really rely on that auxiliary that's
really what the part-time program is
supposed to address uh we just ran an
Academy with 10 people we just we we uh
particularly part-time It's just tough
to generate those numbers the full-time
Academy I have a waiting list uh
part-time
um you know people who have other jobs
they're really very tentative about
jumping into to do this part-time and
I'd love to talk with you more about
um the social worker aspect we can talk
offline and we look forward to that
thank you thank you very much thank you
other questions representative uh gold
thank you madam chair
hi and thank you for taking my question
uh I heard you talk about touch on
specialty areas that you have specialty
areas of training and the ones I'm most
familiar with are from family members
involved in the field and also for my
constituents
is that um PTSD that our First
Responders and police and that in our
district 80 percent of the calls are for
mental health issues and domestic
violence
and so
um I'm assuming that part of the
specialty training that you need to be
have the freedom to bring specialists in
for have to do with those issues those
very unique PTSD and mental health and
how to respond appropriately to mental
health issues in the community
well thank you very much uh for that
question absolutely as a matter of fact
with regard to police officers uh
responding to folks who are having a
mental health crisis we engage with New
Hampshire Nami uh to teach all of that
program just because they're subject
matter experts we do bring in uh peer
support police officers uh and and a lot
of instruction right now that occurs at
the Academy is volunteer uh when we have
outside police instructors that come in
they they are coming here to help uh
that has always been the model at the
New Hampshire Police Academy was to rely
on volunteers uh we do bring peer
support police officers and to teach the
PTSD portion and uh
there is there is a law in place now
that we have to not only introduce that
training at the recruit level but to
make sure that in-service officers
annually are receiving that training
um to including retirees so
thank you madam chair
um so in light of that and kind of
pigtailing on
um representative gerhart's comments
regarding social workers
I'm assuming that putting full-time
instructors in place with those
Specialties might not require 40 hours a
week of training in those specialty
areas and probably you have other
specialty areas as well which is part of
why you need the flexibility to be able
to pull part-time instructors in for
some specialty areas is that correct I I
that that is absolutely correct uh you
know candidly and representative goalie
uh spoke to it earlier if there was a
way for me to increase the full-time
staff uh staying within budget
constraints and be responsible in that
manner I certainly would pursue that and
and have pursued it in the the short two
and a half years that I've been the
director of the police academy
so any steps uh that that I can take to
help augment uh in the meantime while we
build out that full-time staff would be
I was just wondering how many uh
part-time staff do you have uh presently
I have three
okay and one of them uh to uh the
representatives question earlier about
subject matter experts uh we were very
lucky to secure him after a 20-year
career at uh Dover PD who teaches just
crime scene response responding to crime
scenes the collection of evidence which
is a very very narrow uh uh topic area
and we're very lucky to have him
follow-up follow-up and my impression is
you have more more things that are
taught by people that aren't full-time
staff I remember the other people as you
said volunteers or Consultants that are
brought in or you know I was surprised
by how low that number was yeah we we
have always prided ourselves and and I
worked as a training specialist about 20
years ago at the police academy during
my police career uh uh director Sweeney
uh who uh had run the police academy for
a number of years uh really looked at at
police standards and training as kind of
a credit union where uh everybody added
a little something right and and uh
everybody could volunteer a little bit
of time and we could benefit uh
tremendously throughout our state uh the
unfortunate truth is that
um because there is that 20 reduction in
staff across the board uh because it's
just kind of a new way of looking at the
world where you know people have an
expectation to be compensated for their
time
I don't know that that model has surv
we still rely on it very heavily
thank you thank you sir other questions
representative Wilhelm thank you madam
chair thanks for taking my question you
mentioned the Lee act commission
recommendations and how that's uh
increased training time from eight hours
to 24 hours and also said it was a
three-year uh investment of time is it
is it
24 hours over the course of the three
years or is it 24 hours per year so
thank you for this question uh
uh presently it would check that last
year every certified officer had to
complete eight hours of in-service
training within that that calendar year
to maintain their certification uh this
year that number has gone up a little
bit to 10 and then it will go to 18 the
year after that and then 24 so they'll
have to complete 24 hours of training
within that calendar a year and that
really kind of brings us up to about a
national average as compared to other
states
follow-up
uh and so once it hits 24
it will continue to be 24 year over year
uh based on existing uh language in the
law and administrative rule yes great
I I have a comment I certainly hope that
since the liac commission imposed
significant extra responsibilities on
your organization more training hours
the conduct review committees and things
like that that you've pointed that out
to the governor in your budget requests
yes you have okay good yes Madam it's uh
because seriously if you're being asked
to do more work with the same staff it's
not really fair for the staff so
dependent
all right any other questions
thank you very much Madam chair members
thank you very much for your time okay
thank you madam chair again for the
record Marty Carlin representing the New
Hampshire retirement system I signed up
to testify just to provide some
background information on the current uh
statutory landscape regarding retirees
working
um for participating Employers in the
state of New Hampshire
um the law lies overall governing
working after retirement were last
changed in the 2018 session uh effective
1-1 of 19 and under the current law
retired members
um who are collecting a pension can work
up in whoever retired since
um
since the law change can work
1352 hours per calendar year
so that's not a weekly limit it's not a
monthly limit it's it's a calendar year
limit that averages out to 26 hours a
week but it doesn't mandate that they
can't work more than 26 hours in a given
week as long as it's not a temporary uh
permanent full-time position with you
know regularly scheduled to work more
hours
retirees can work you know
30 40 50 hours if it's a seasonal
part-time you know um you know detail
work at Hampton Beach working at a state
park in the summer or plowing in the
winter things like that so so so that
the the prior statute was a weekly limit
of 30 no more than 32 hours so that was
a hard stop on every single week uh this
change while it reduced the hours for
new retirees
um to an average of 26 it gives more
flexibility within the calendar year
employers report hours work by retirees
to the New Hampshire retirement system
at the beginning of the the next
calendar year so we're actually
accepting um
reports from participating employers now
through February 15th
um
if if there's also a there's a
grandfathering provision put in the law
uh back in 2018 that said that any
retiree already working in a part-time
position
was allowed to work a total of
1664 hours in a calendar year that
averages out to 32 hours a week for as
long as they stayed in that same
position with the same employer so if
somebody
left town X to go to town y
um you know they would be limited to the
1352 but so there were some
grandfathered folks who were still
working up to 1664 hours in a calendar
year now both the 13th uh 52 and the uh
1664. our cumulative hours worked by the
retiree for one or more employers so in
other words you can't work 1500 1300
hours for one employer and 1300 for
another you know the the hours follow
the retiree so you know we don't know
how many people are working for multiple
employers or for how much until those
employers report the numbers back into
us the following year
um
the um there was a penalty for exceeding
the statutory limits right now which is
um if if you know you were actually
worked over the limits the state portion
of the member's pension would be
withheld for 12 months
um which on average is about half the
pension it could be more of of the
benefit or it could be less depending on
um various factors and the members work
history and salary history but um since
the law has been enacted only one person
has gone over it
um and also uh there are there is um one
there's there are some exceptions to
those hours work limits right now
um it's um it's a section that says that
ours worked under the direction of the
division of Fire
uh fighting uh no forest fires in the in
the North Country hours doing that are
Exempted and also any hours worked by
anyone during a state of emergency
declared by the governor now until covid
um my my friends at the department of
safety told me that there were only 12
declared emergencies by the governor
Statewide since the 1950s however
essentially New Hampshire was in a state
of emergency for 14 months so pretty
much anybody who was a retiree who
worked in either calendar year 20 or 21
wasn't going to exceed those hours
because none of them counted
um so that that's one of the reasons
we've only seen one person so far so
um with that background I just just be
glad to answer any questions about the
law and how that works and it actually I
will mention that the 1352 is the
highest number of hours among all the
New England states and among the highest
okay other questions representative
O'Brien and then representative Gould
thank you for taking my question and
thank you madam chair uh Mr College
um
Chief uh Phillips mentioned the
cumulative effect that you said it it
came at a later date you know in in the
history but uh because I did remember
when the numbers were mentioned 25 years
I remember it being at 32 and you know
it was something everybody watched but
the thing is if we are we heading in the
retirements uh
nhrs physician are we heading the right
direction to solve a problem here would
it be looking at the cumulative effect
and modifying that to some degree
workable would that be a better way to
go about this
um I I'm not sure how to directly answer
your question but just just as by way of
background the the 32-hour weekly limit
was enacted in 2011 and prior to that
there was nothing in the statute per se
about retirees working
um you know after collecting a benefit
and working for participating employer
so by default we referred to our
administrative rules which Define
full-time for employees teachers police
and fire so in reality uh anyone who was
working a half an hour less a week than
what's defined as full time in the rules
you know was fine there were some cases
that made the headlines back then that
led to the 2032 and then the decennial
commission looked at that and
um at as an issue and then the um
uh was was turned to the 1352 was is a
cumulative piece now in terms of the
retirement system the only
um impact retirees working uh after
retirement and collecting a benefit on
us is when those retirees are
replacing full-time positions that
remain unfilled so if if you hired a you
know a
10 part-timers to do the work of five
full-timers that's five people five
positions we're no longer receiving uh
contributions on
um for the unfunded liability uh and
those that money still needs to come
into us so you know to the extent that
more positions of active members are
removed from the system the rates go up
on the remaining members in the system
and all employers
pay pay a little bit more
um than they they would on a per person
basis so that that's that's our only
um
concern from a funding perspective with
I follow up thank you madam chair uh
would you be willing if if the chair
agrees I don't know uh uh what the
prognosis of this is but if we decide to
put it into a committee which you work
with the committee to look at that
cumulative and see what would be the
best way to you know dive deeper into
this absolutely of course it's at the
college yeah yes well actually it will
be going to the pension subcommittee
primarily because there's an amendment
to be looked at that we need to discuss
and I'd like to mention for the benefit
of the committee that the reason there
is a limit on part-time employment is
exactly what Mr Carlin said that
employers would have a an incentive to
replace
full-time with part-time people because
they don't have to pay the benefits
which
the pension contribution is a large part
of it
um
that's a way that
that
helps the employer in the short term but
it hurts the retirement system in the
long term and so we are
in 2011 it was decided that we should
not be allowing that because
not to mention the fact that it is a
public relations nightmare when you're
school superintendent retires and comes
back to the exact same job part-time
while so he's collecting his pension and
a slightly reduced
pay and the retirement system doesn't
we can talk about that okay so this will
be going to the pension subcommittee and
they will be uh
looking at these issues
is that's the last card is there anyone
else who wishes to testify
representative Gould oh I'm sorry
forgive me that's quite all right thank
you madam chair I'm not sure if this
question is appropriate to go to you or
not but you can let me know that I heard
you talk about you don't get the data on
the cumulative hours until the end of
the year when they're reported in and
previously we heard testimony that the
managers on the job the directors on the
in the different departments don't have
access to the data about hours worked in
various departments
as someone who's managed these kind of
programs that seems like a huge issue to
me
representative Gould yes the problem is
not their work that they're working for
another department in the state they're
working for a Small Town Police or fire
department that doesn't
look at this data more frequently than
once a year and that was my question is
there a way and this is going to study
committee so nobody has to tell me an
answer here but I just hope that that
whole issue of lack of data will be part
of the consideration moving forward
okay then we'll take a look at that
thank you thank you hopefully the
employee the person involved is keeping
track but that's the only person who can
if they are say working at the
Warren and Webster fire departments
you know something or something like
that nobody else wouldn't would know
follow up
quite common
so any other questions for Mr Carla
yes
okay you got to follow us thank you
representative true
thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question
so the hours worked of a retired fireman
not only the hours worked for a fire
department
it depends I mean we actually probably
fire retirees or have the the smallest
amount of ability to work for fire
department part-time typically those are
you know full-time more volunteer
positions but
um we we you know a retired firefighter
could work as a substitute teacher you
know or you know it they people can can
move around within different you know if
different positions were for political
subdivisions it's not all straight you
know firefighters are only retired
Fighters will only work you know in in
the fire service they they there's
there's wiggle room thank you to any any
participating employer which means every
so any anyone else
all right thank you thank you yes
representative just Just for information
purposes uh a retiree could work at the
local grocery store as many hours as he
wants because they don't contribute to
the retirement system
right
absolutely true anyone else
all right thank you is there any other
member of the public who would like to
all right seeing none I will close the
public hearing open the hearing on House
all right hello I'm representative Tony
leckis
um
in Hillsboro 38 representing the towns
of Hudson and Litchfield so
this bill is uh kind of an
administrative cleanup bill that came in
at a request of the retirement system
it's got eight pieces in here rather
than uh abusing the committee with eight
separate bills so
um if the chair is okay with it what I'm
going to do is give a brief overview
of each section
and deal with any questions there and if
we have uh Marty Carlin from the
retirement system and Matt Kavanaugh an
attorney for the retirement system who
uh you know should be able to answer
questions I can't
so
um the first one is cleaning up the
language around a teacher job sharing I
guess there are
situations where two teachers I suppose
more but well it's two
they're basically covering the same job
and that's like to give them flexibility
for for various reasons and then this
deals with uh you know how is the
pension handled in that kind of a
situation
um and the intent of of this change is
to clarify what equally share means in
that context and to have this language
also coordinated with other languages in
um
and you can see the language here now
there was a request for an amendment
that came in yesterday from
a representative from the the Nea
it sent email out about that and it just
changes a couple words and I mean it
adds a couple words and changes one and
the intent there is to
clarify
exactly what this means I guess there
was a situation in the past around this
where there was a dispute between
employees and the school district
about the interpretation of it and the
retirement system you know adjudicated
that and actually agreed with the
employee but the change was intended to
avoid that kind of a thing in the future
and if there's questions on the details
on that there's someone else here who
can speak on it but so any questions on
or I'll take them yeah sorry yes I do
you have a
um you do have the amendment I don't
I've requested it from OLS I have not
gotten it back
okay I sent the request in last night
got it which is why you haven't got it
yet okay thank you very much
okay
all right in that case
um can move on to section two
and this is declare this um
has to do with how the retirement system
handles uh compensation for
extra special Duty which I think is
mainly police officers maybe others I
don't know
um
and
the the issue is as I understand it is
that there are things that look like
special duty but if they're being funded
um by a third party let's say a Federal
Grant or something else
um then it should be true the intent is
to treat it as their normal employment
pay and not you know actually special
Duty and um and this is just to clarify
that
so any fair question no questions on
that I can move on
uh like
percent of O'Brien
um representative electus I'm unclear
but I know in my former Department we
have people that do military duty and
they have to go on assignments would
this affect them because no that that's
this is um
like if the police are doing Special
Duty like there's uh uh there's a
utility work being done and uh so
they're flagging you know they often you
know they have to be present for that
and that's paid for them by the utility
or contractor or whatever thank you
actually there are other sections here
actually dealing with the military
good
okay thank you okay uh moving on to
section three
um
it's in it's resolving an ambiguity
between the term newly appointed and
newly uh created
and actually if there's questions on
okay
all right on to section four
um there were
this was dealt with in two parts of the
statute in 183
Roman 4B and
4A
address basically the same thing and in
one case
um you know this is for uh
withdrawn service purchase
what that is one of them it had a time
frame of a year the other one um six
months and
so we the statute made it impossible for
the retirement system to follow the law
since it was internally inconsistent and
this would um
I don't know if you have anything else
you could say about the details on what
this
yeah this is um if if someone who has
previously withdrawn contributions from
the retirement system for any reason you
know they were terminated and they took
their money out or they chose to stop
working and then they're working for
another employer and they want to buy
that time back it puts a six-month
minimum purchase on that that's six
months is in another statute and that's
how we've treated it administratively
but this section that would be change
refers to one month so we wanted to
bring those in sync
um and that would track with um current
practice
foreign
that answers the question I'll move on
to
um
a minor grammatical point but if we
adopt that the apostrophe s would have
to change to s apostrophe
um
line 30 Mr grammar person that is
absolutely correct
okay another amendment for opal oh no no
you just that's editorial oh okay fine
but we have to Adaptive enough we have
to adopt it first yeah okay
um you need a staff grammarian I guess
well it's representative psychic on the
position is open yes well we should have
a new volunteer it seems so okay
um
see
well actually I'll leave this to Marty
it has to do with uh you know there are
times when people have to enroll and
what if they don't
yes there is a provision in the law that
allows uh if a member through no fault
of their own was
um not enrolled by the employer or upon
hire you know there was a clerical error
or a misunderstanding of some sort that
um you know they can uh once that's
identified they can petition for service
credit uh on that in both the the member
pays in the the member contribution
based on the time that they should have
been enrolled and the employer pays the
employer contribution on that and this
um adds the the phrase not to put the
person's election not to participate
which just clarifies and puts the onus
on the um presumption of fault is with
the employer in those cases not the
member
okay if there's no questions I'll go on
to part six and again I'm going to turn
this over to Marty because what this has
to do is uh clarifying
uh what happens for a military service
members who cycle in and out of being
with the military and then going back
under the retirement system and and how
that's all handled
I'm probably going to have attorney
Kavanaugh jump in over my shoulder on a
couple of these especially if they're
questions but he he as our associate
counsel and compliance officer deals
with these questions when they come up
and also drafted these changes which is
why it's great to have them uh here
today but under my understanding this
portion does two things there's some
additional unnecessary language that it
cleans up and it also clarifies the
current provision regarding uh what
portion of military service credit is
free of cost and what requires the
member to pay right now there are two
types of military service credit
available in the statute and the change
deals with one where an active
participating member of the retirement
system is called to active military duty
and that was much more common 10 15
years ago than it is now but it's still
quite possible with a lot of folks
serving uh you know in the guard of the
reserves things like that so
um the
way we've interpreted this the current
law is that if someone is deployed
returns you know finishes their
deployment and comes back to work they
can get up to three years of service
added to their member record at no cost
to them but but it is ambiguous
um whether that arguably is per
deployment or poorer
are cumulative so that's what we're
looking to clarify with that piece uh
and the second piece is uh sort of a fun
uh not fun but interesting uh that we're
our statute is not in compliance with
federal law regarding
um
purchase of prior military service we
have a provision in our law that says
you can only purchase purchase prior
military service this is service
given before you've joined nhrs as a
contributing member
um you can only make that purchase if
you're not already collecting a military
pension and that that's conflicts with
with federal law that says that people
can do that you have to have at least 10
years of service with nhrs to buy the
prior military service and you can buy
up to three years
so this would strike out the provisions
that are in conflict with federal law
one of uh one of your colleagues
representative Lynn a former member of
the judicial branch pointed that out to
us last year so we we haven't been in
following the current law but we want to
get it uh income Department with uh
you know the federal statutes
yeah representative since we're talking
about service credits I if we can go
back I just want to uh page two lines
three and four it mentioned civilian
national service Americorps and the
Peace Corps
would you mind just explaining sort of
how that works because it almost feels
similarly vague to what was there before
and maybe we need to clarify that as
well yeah that that was a provision that
was added uh
oh did you want to go yeah
first I'll say I know when they're
taking advantage of that information no
one's asked for to buy service related
to Peace Corps or ameriser but it does
date date back quite uh please we can't
um it is a provision that was put in in
quite a few years ago
uh it was modified uh
about five years ago in terms of how the
cost of it would be calculated but
basically says if you go off to Peace
Corps Service for a couple years and
come back you can buy that two years of
service and add it to your service if
you come back to your job in the system
quite similar to the military the
military one is different in that you
have you Sarah the uniform Service Act
it's a federal statute it says if you go
leave your job to go back into military
service they have to hold that job for
you and
allow you to buy time so you maintain
your seniority and your service credit
it doesn't require that uh
that the plan give any free time you can
charge the person the full cost we have
a statute that we interpreted to say
that cumulatively up to three years of
service would be free and then the
member could pay for any additional
years of service
uh one reason we changed this is it was
ambiguous and in fact on Tuesday our
board upheld a recommendation of our
hearings examiner that the three years
is per deployment because a member had
argued he had four different deployments
that added up to by five years of
service he said I should get three years
for each time I was deployed and because
of the strict statutory construction and
the ambiguity the hearings examined a
recommended to the board that they that
they uh allow this person to get what
amounted to almost five years of free
service that's contrary to how we had
been applying it before so it's very
germane now to correct this three years
is very high amount for free service a
lot of states don't give any free
service some give some free service if
you win a certain medal for Valor or
this or that
um there are different constructs three
years is one of the highest ones and we
just wanted to put a long-standing
practice into places especially in light
of we knew this hearing was coming down
the pike
as far as the provision uh
uh that was against the law so to speak
that was brought to our attention by a
former New Hampshire Supreme Court
Justice that there was a Rhode Island
case two years ago that said you can't
discriminate in granting benefits under
a private pension or government pension
because of someone's eligibility or
receipt of a military pension that
was in a Rhode Island District Court
didn't come to our attention but it was
also citing a California District Court
decision that predated our statute so
that provision our statute was wrong
from the day it was enacted
um and so that's why we wanted to take
the questions representative Schmidt so
not to shortchange the committee but
isn't this discussion a little bit more
appropriate for the subcommittee since
it's going to subcommittee uh we're
getting into all the nitty-gritty that
that's what the subcommittee is supposed
to be doing and anybody who wants to sit
in on that uh is welcome to do so yes
thank you representative this is going
to the to the pension subcommittee it is
a it is a little bit more than uh
technical cleanup it is yeah
this is a policy that's a policy
decision to say it's three cumulative
rather than three per deployment
um if I could just finish up the two
these 10x2 I think should be simple and
then I'll call it a day for for this
um section seven and eight they both
um they're actually redundant language
in the statute and it just removes the
Redundant language that is a cleanup one
um and then the last one is really
simple uh section nine there are a
number of places
um
that stated that the you know some work
that the retirement system did had to uh
comply with a particular government
Standards Board and the name of that
government Standards Board changed and
and uh are there any any questions any
other questions representative O'Brien
yes just uh thinking putting my
Municipal hat on the effective date 60
days after passage uh do you feel that's
adequate for the contributing
uh subdivisions to get up to speed with
us these
um these changes wouldn't affect any
reporting from the participating
employers or any contribution or things
like that they're more sort of
individual Case by case uh changes or
they just have no impact like they're
removing their redundant language so we
don't believe there's any programming or
other questions
okay
thank you that will in fact be going to
the pension subcommittee for uh further
analysis
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house wait a minute Brian
Hawkins
thank you madam chair uh for the record
Brian Hawkins um here representing Nea
New Hampshire today we represent uh 17
000 teachers paraprofessionals other
School Employees across the state
um and uh as representative lakis uh
first welcome to the new members
um and welcome back to to the returning
ones
um and uh I want to thank uh
representative lakis for uh submitting
um the amendment that we
requested to O to OLS
um
I did hear that the uh the chair
mentioned that you are going to send it
to a subcommittee
um and so you know I'm happy to go this
is fairly brief but uh I had I do have I
did bring some copies of a Word document
Amendment if you would like me to hand
that out for reference or I can save
that will help us understand the intent
and it's likely the exact the language
yes and and the language would be very
similar I don't it would not change the
intent of what the retirement system was
trying to do I I did have a we did talk
to the retirement system
um and um our understanding is that they
have no issue with the change
um the first uh you'll see is when in
the Amendments uh to the to
excuse me on the bill
on on page one
line nine it would change the tense of
designates to designated
and the purpose of that is to uh you
know the the designation of job share is
is the employers and the and the purpose
of that is just to clarify that
um when the employer makes that
designation further down the road
um you know two years from now uh which
was a situation that did happen or
attempted to happen that uh you know
somebody who's been paying into the
system and the employer has been making
those contributions that that was for
for that semester that was the
designation for that position of course
the employer can change that in the next
uh semester it could be changed to a
part-time situation which is not uh
which which may not be you know a
pensionable position in the retirement
system
so that there's the tense change there
the second change
um is uh and I apologize that this is
not in color I bet Anya New Hampshire
for three years and apparently they
haven't given me color position
permissions on the uh on the printer yet
but
uh the the additional languages period
what's that it's a 10-year vest yes
10-year vesting on color permissions
uh I think that may be in the law too I
don't know uh
so this this would uh apply to
um
on line 10 of the bill
um where it says scheduled to work 50 of
the regularly scheduled days this would
add or hours and the purpose of that is
is more to just clearly reflect the
nature that is some job shares which
it's not
working on your work on Monday I work on
Tuesday it may be a situation where you
have you know two working moms who
they're covering a PE instructor
position for example in the morning and
then someone else in the afternoon so
that's more just to make it clear that
we're we're not just talking about uh
different days so that and that I with
that I don't have any other comments
other than uh once again to thank
representative lakis for uh the
conversation yesterday and and
submitting that to OS and we'll be happy
to
attend and work with the subcommittee
when when it meets
hey
coach are there any questions
representative true
um thank you madam chair uh we'll need
at least three more copies of oh
thank you
foreign
okay I don't see any more questions is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
thank you very much on House Bill 193
. all right seeing none I will close the
public hearing
foreign
good afternoon welcome to Edna I'm
opening the public hearing on cacr1 and
I'm calling
will I'm sure prepare a pink card before
he leaves
thank you madam chair we'll get right to
this uh and we have some weather today
I'm actually presenting two bills at 1
30 or this is on a Bill's uh cacr and I
wanted to make sure I was here I want to
thank representative the other
representative leckis for covering me in
the other
committee
so for the record iron state
representative Mike Moffett representing
Merrimack District 4 in the beautiful
towns of Canterbury and Loudoun
so Calvin Coolidge who most of you have
heard of uh famously once said
persistence is omnipotent and his point
was that uh stay with things don't give
up in fact Winston Churchill in the most
famous
commencement speech ever was three words
don't give up and that's why I'm here
today we've had this measure before
and uh it's back for a good reason
because a lot of folks are hoping that
it would come back so here we are
um
Constitutional Amendment concurrent
resolution one cacr1 is a measure
establishing a lieutenant governor
position for the State of New Hampshire
so and I have sent my testimony to the
committee already and I have
um also forwarded on a former
representative sent me some information
about Lieutenant Governors which I've
also sent to you all as well maybe some
of you a chance to look at it and if you
haven't uh it's in your both of those
are in your inboxes
so uh currently 43 states have
Lieutenant governors
now I know that is not a reason for us
necessarily to do this just because
Massachusetts does anything doesn't
necessarily mean that we need to uh
follow in their footsteps but
um there are there's a strong case for
uh given giving this serious
consideration which I hope uh is the
case
constitutionally a current line of
succession calls for the state senate
president
to replace the governor and this has
happened several times most recently in
when Senate President Chuck Morse
replaced uh Governor Maggie hasson
briefly when she was sworn in to be a
U.S senator
Senate President Ralph Howe
which some of you may remember from he's
from Lebanon he replaced Judd Gregg in
1992 briefly same reason when uh
Judd Gregg was um
sworn in as a U.S senator but please
Ponder what happened in 1982
when Senate President Vesta Roy was
sworn in as acting Governor after the
death of of you gallon of Littleton
so these two individuals Governor Gowan
and Senator Vester lawyer of different
priorities
and that's uh could have been
problematical had Governor gallon won
re-election against John sununo
um and passed away later in the term we
would have had a uh a Republican
uh speak a Republican senator Senate
President replacing a a Democratic
governor
and that just is a problem and it's a
problem for uh for all kind
of S Marine for all concerned and
this measure that you have in front of
you is a non-partisan measure because in
the future we just don't know uh who
will be in which positions it's
non-partisan also bipartisan uh the last
time this came through I had a couple uh
co-sponsors who are now in the Senate
interestingly uh but my my three
co-sponsors this time around are from
the other party so this is true this is
a constitutional issue and it's truly
bipartisan and non-partisan
so to have a president Senate President
one party replace
a government of another party creates
potentially many issues and I I've
emailed my testimony to you all as well
as well as some information about how
other states do lieutenant governor
issues so were this to happen and it has
happened in the past I just gave you
three examples but those are very brief
uh short-term situations what if this
happened midterm and that's something
that is very very important and very
significant we've been lucky that we
haven't had this come up before so I
just really needs to be looked at
so if a new governor came in would the
new governor replace existing staff
that's a good question would the new
governor from the other party
bring his or her people in or not or or
have a hybrid who knows it's it's very
unwieldy and here's the biggest nub or
the thing that really needs to be
pondered and considered and it's
extremely significant that it needs to
be addressed
how can you have the
the leader of a legislative branch the
Senate President concurrently at the
same time become the leader of the
executive branch again I'm the guy who
got the two Civics bills to the
governor's desk I used to teach this
stuff and it's it's important and I
asked I ask again how can you have a
lead in New Hampshire leader this is
separation of powers issues how can you
have the Senate President also be the
head of the executive branch and that's
the situation we have now it's untenable
it just needs to be talked about I'm
surprised it hasn't been talked about
before
um
I did bring this measure to committee
before as I said it received some
support I noticed from both sides of the
aisle then but not enough to move it
forward so I'll try to present it better
this time around
so
as I said the subtle the current
uh structure we have utterly goes
against uh separation powers in civics
101. so Ponder what would have happened
in 2019 or 2020 had God forbid heaven
forbid governor of sonuna would have
been say struck by lightning uh Senate
President Donna Souci at the time would
have taken over to his office to finish
out his term that's what we have in
place now
so again what would she have done with
the staff would she have like fired his
people brought her own people in I don't
know but something that uh is a question
that needs to be pondered
um what would have happened with regard
to running the Senate she's the Senate
President is she not going to run the
Senate anymore she's not going to vote
in the Senate while she's running the
state because she would be sworn in as
the governor I mean
seriously what would have happened now
that's what Senators Roy Huffman Morse
did but they again they were only in
there for the short term
and further in 2019 to 2020 is most all
of you will will recall uh one party had
both U.S senators had both Congress
people had the state senate had the
State House of Representatives had the
executive Council and if the party would
at that point also get in the governor
we would have a situation in this purple
state where one party would have
controlled every single part of state
government now the reverse situation was
true in 1982 when Governor Gallen died
and was replaced by Senate President
investor Roy at that time the
Republicans pretty much controlled every
part of the government and and we would
have had a uh reverse situation that's
why this is a very non-partisan and
bipartisan
situation
so New Hampshire is one of only two
states that has a two-year term for
governor that mitigates the problem the
situation somewhat uh you know if it was
a four-year term it'll be even worse
even more compelling
so Madam chairman is a potentially
serious situation that's just not an
issue in other states because most other
states have a reasonable working line of
succession
so uh I bring this forward I
because it needs to be addressed and
needs to be talked about
and the proposal here in cacr1 is to do
this though the New Hampshire as I call
it the New Hampshire way uh we're all
citizen legislators very proud of that
and the proposal here uh
is I think a very exciting proposal to
have a citizen lieutenant governor
a lot of the folks especially from my
team have said to me you know uh you're
growing government you know we don't
want to grow government well no I I'm
not a big on growing government
government either
but for 125 a year which is what the
Senate President gets our citizen
lieutenant governor which we would have
if this moves forward out of this
committee and goes to the Senate doesn't
go to the as you know this doesn't go to
the governor it goes to the people
Governor it's a cacr and I I would hope
obviously that this would go to the
Senate and then to the people it'd be a
wonderful civics lesson because there'd
be a lot of discussion all over the
state about the structure of our
government a lot of people would learn
some stuff and they get smarter
so two government two Governors for the
price of one essentially I think that
that's not bigger government that's
better government
our governor gets countless
invitations all the time more than he or
she could ever begin to uh
to respond to
ribbon cuttings testimonials funerals
School visits you know meeting people
the governor is like a scheduler just to
deal with his schedule or her schedule
uh Lieutenant government would would
double
the executive office's capacity to serve
the people to to meet with these
youngsters from the fourth graders who
come here I mean I could go on and on
and on and on about all the great things
that a lieutenant a citizen lieutenant
governor could do
so again the uh I mentioned this is very
non-partisan because we have no way of
knowing who's going to be in power in
the future so it's again some will argue
we've
we've never done that before which
I've heard and I uh I just understand
that that that's a natural question for
people to say we've got we've got along
for 240 years without a lieutenant
governor we've never done that before we
don't need that well just because every
other state has one doesn't mean that we
need one but those are all flawed
arguments in my opinion and hopefully
when this measure goes to your executive
session they can be appropriately
discussed and refuted
uh last time I was here two years ago
there were some good questions as a
former teacher Professor I know there's
no such thing as bad questions but some
of the questions that came up before
some of you were here
um
I was asked will the lieutenant governor
have their own desk
will the lieutenant governor have their
own phone
who's going to pay for the business
cards for the new lieutenant governor
those are all no such thing as a bad
question those are all questions that's
why we have these these hearings these
questions come out and the answer is
that the governor whoever he or she may
be really would Define or determine how
they want to use their lieutenant
governor not unlike a president will
make uh
uh vice president tsar of whatever and I
think it's very exciting I think uh
Governors uh to have this help and to be
able to assign all these things to a
citizen lieutenant governor uh just
would just make our government better
more responsive better
so
um and the answer is the governor would
make that decision and and the
lieutenant governor would work for the
governor and for us and for the people
of New Hampshire
so real quick I was on a radio show
Monday talking about this and the radio
host was very excited the more he
learned about it he said this is a great
idea when we've done this before and I
said well we're trying again Calvin
Coolidge persistence is omnipotent
so anyway I explained him the process if
this gets through this committee which
hopefully it will into the Senate and
then to the people
the people will eventually vote on this
it's a constitutional amendment
and uh if if we don't like our flawed
succession plan I'm afraid that someday
they'll there will be a midterm
gubernatorial vacancy in subsequent
chaos
in some future Edna committee will then
likely recommend well we've got to fix
this we need a lieutenant governor
position but if if that's what happens
down the road whenever
I'm sure that there'll be a it'll be
structured differently they'll say well
we need to pay the lieutenant governor
125 000 dollars
as opposed to doing it the New Hampshire
way with the
citizen lieutenant governor all for 125
a year so I think we can do this and we
should do this and finally if it will
help move this measure forward
I pledge at this time I will personally
pay the lieutenant Governor's salary the
first year thank you madam chair and I'd
be happy to take any questions if there
are any
throw an offer like that how can we
refuse does anyone have any questions
representative Simon
thank you representative muffin
um my my question is when I'm looking at
the bill I don't see that the governor
and the lieutenant governor would be
running on the same ticket is that
correct now yes they would if you read
through that
um I don't make glasses on no when we
set this up with OLS we made it clear
that they would run as a ticket and if
if you read down the measure it it
should make that clear
15. okay yeah I see it yeah it's a great
question and I think we addressed it and
of course uh the committee now owns this
measure and and uh obviously can tweak
it or do whatever you you want to do
thank you that's
that's clear anyone else versus Gerhart
do you have a question
thank you madam chair do you miss uh
representative Moffett do you personally
see somebody coming in to greet students
every day and do all these ribbon
cuttings for 125 a year just for The
Prestige of being lieutenant governor
good question thank you for the question
representative the answer yes absolutely
look at all of us you know we're all
here for for less than 125 a year and uh
I think that uh it to me it's very
exciting you know how would this be
filled in the ticket with with the
future Governor Pickett an elder
Statesman like I won't name any names uh
somebody who's been around for a long
time and has gravitas and wisdom uh or
would they pick a young up-and-comer and
again I won't point to anybody uh who
was a young up-and-comer to groom them
perhaps for future opportunities so
absolutely I think people would would
love to have this and they see it more
ceremonial yes it would be ceremonial
but it would also be uh substantive does
that kind of answer your question
sorta thank you
okay representative a bear
and then representative true thank you
madam chair
thank you representative Moffett for
being here
my question to you is why would we have
the lieutenant governor run on the same
ticket if as as written
thing representative another great
question because my answer would be that
we would want the uh the ticket to be in
sync uh there are a couple states where
they're elected separately and I don't
personally I don't think that's a great
model I think that you could elect a
a lieutenant governor who is maybe of a
different party or different philosophy
than the governor again some of you I
know some of you know some history uh
when our country started the president
was elected by the electors and the
voters and the vice president was
elected separately
and we quickly found out that didn't
work so well uh especially when one of
the Vice Presidents shot and killed
Alexander Hamilton and we eventually
made that a ticket so this is similar to
your great question that's why and also
the representative Simon's question it I
think it should be a ticket so they're
percent of true
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
I don't see where uh
it is addressed in your in the
Constitutional Amendment
how the lieutenant governor has chosen
um the
as you go through a primary and the
winner of the primary on the Democrat
side if it's a Democrat Governor would
be matched up at that time it only
mentions November
sure thank you representative another
great question that's even a better
question than the one about uh do they
get a desk so my answer to that would be
like in most case Most states uh and
again you have the opportunity to tweak
the language if this moves forward uh to
make clear that they would run as a
ticket and that's the way it happens in
Most states uh the governor is uh
in the in his or her running mate run as
a ticket so in the primary and this is
kind of interesting it is a service I
think it's fun and exciting uh to have
tickets now so that uh
you have you get to vote for two instead
of one so that's how I see this
thank you madam chair
so representative uh
uh in all seriousness if the lieutenant
governor is going to be taking over the
ribbon cutting and such ceremonial
activities then he or she is going to
have uh to have a separate vehicle a
separate driver because the governor
doesn't drive himself around he he's
driven by a State Trooper who is also
his in this case bodyguard
but also his driver because we don't
want the governor having a traffic
accident
and possibly being killed as a result of
being maybe not the best driver in the
world but the point is that uh that
there's going to be aside from the 125
dollars which I'm glad to hear you would
pick up uh the the cost of the staff for
this lieutenant governor is is a
definite expansion of government so uh
the lieutenant governor is not going to
be answering his or her own phone I
believe uh or you know welcoming people
to his or her office which would have to
be provided and so forth so they're
they're going to be Staffing costs and
have you given any thought to what kind
of cost would be involved to handle all
the security and and other
administrative functions that this
lieutenant governor would be doing so
that's question number one thank you
representative Schmidt and that that
really is is a great question and it's
one you know we're sailing into some
uncharted waters so to speak and
questions like that uh yes
um the governor would have especially if
this ever moves forward then the first
lieutenant governor governor situation
would be setting a lot of Precedence uh
and of course every president every
Governor handles their staff differently
uh you're right that's an excellent
point there are some other expenses now
would would the governor would the
lieutenant governor if he or she had to
go to represent the governor in
Portsmouth for whatever would they have
a state car uh I would say probably I
mean if I was lieutenant governor I
would I would offer to drive myself but
you make a good point
you can't have the person in line to
receive the governor not being you know
having security so there would be some
class and expenses there would they be
daunting
um I I don't know exactly uh what those
costs might entail I think they could be
fairly minimal if it depends how active
the lieutenant governor is going to be
how much they're going to travel uh good
question but I think those are
manageable and it would be up to the
governor to decide how broadly how much
they want to use their lieutenant
governor and as you said I I've offered
to pay the first salary but not the
I think we had to have something in
writing from you with regard to how much
of the additional costs which it you're
you're saying that the governor is going
to do is going to declare and determine
what the functions of the lieutenant
governor are going to be in
the president does have a lot of say
with regard to how much the vice
president is taking care of and the Czar
you mentioned of this or that current
crisis or critical situation but but uh
I don't think uh that that a
a governor is going to be able to have
free will and free Reign Over what the
lieutenant governor is going to do
um and so that I I'm that I'm asking you
the cost involved uh are going to be
more considerable and where have you
given some thought to the governor has a
residence in New Hampshire
rarely uses it but uh where would the
lieutenant governor live
so again uh you make a good point uh
there is an Air Force too we don't know
about Air Force One there is an Air
Force too that the vice president uses
so we're some version of that to come
here to New Hampshire uh again I can't I
don't want to necessarily speak for some
future Governor uh depends you know some
governments may want to minimize what
they invest in this new position in
terms of uh support uh so I don't want
to speak for a future Governor if if I
was a governor which I never will be I
would probably try to uh you know be as
efficient as I could uh coordinate
schedules have the lieutenant governor
use my vehicle when I'm not using it to
be efficient and Frugal but those are
things that issues that don't need to be
part of the Constitution those are
administrative type questions that the
governor's office and the governor has a
budget
I think yes if this move forward I think
the government's budget might have to go
up uh a minimal amount
um
TBD to be determined we depend on the
governor
um you had said and I think perhaps
somewhat optimistically that that the
candidate lieutenant governor candidate
would be chosen for their gravitas and
their wisdom
um what I hear more frequently perhaps
unfairly
with the president of the vice president
as they're choosing some someone that
won't outshine them I'm sorry I didn't
catch your lip more often I hear in the
news that the vice president has chosen
either for their location that they're
providing another location but also
someone that won't outshine the
president a lesser entity right rather
than gravitas and wisdom
yes
um
Senator Dan Quayle comes to mind when
you when you say that um
uh vice president Quail so again this to
me this gets to the exciting part of
this would there be a political
component to having a ticket of course
and I'm sure the wheels are turning in
some heads thinking okay if this moves
forward to your point
um should we have a male female old
young somebody from the North Country a
geographical balance I don't know but I
think Ali's potential combinations are
exciting and the gravitas issue I mean
it's up to the if if you have a really
young person running for for governor
they may go for the gravitas or older uh
running mate if you ever really
older the the other way around you might
if there's a really old old I'd say old
uh more seasoned candidate running for
governor I would see them potentially
picking somebody younger younger to as I
said earlier to potentially groom them
for future service I I think it's really
exciting this might evolve in the future
but I think it's exciting to think about
thank you
okay
uh thank you yeah I had a question on
the idea of doing it the New Hampshire
way
um so we would have a governor that
makes a fairly substantial salary and
then a lieutenant governor that would
make 125
within that Paradigm and with the amount
of control that the governor would have
in delineating the responsibilities of
the lieutenant governor how can we be
assured that the lieutenant governor
would be adequately prepared to take on
the role of the governor should
something happen to the governor because
if the governor's just say they do just
want to use them for ribbon cuttings
ceremonies things of that nature they're
not super involved in the political
process whereas at least the Senate
President is familiar with everything
that's going on at that particular point
in time how can we ensure that that
person would be better prepared than the
Senate President uh to fill that role
sure thank you for the question I am
sure that if this moved forward whoever
was running for governor and was going
to have a ticket they would vet their
running mate uh extremely closely for
all kinds of things you know what's your
variants do they have any skeletons in
their closet what are their skills do
they get along with each other
I I have no doubt that anyone if this
moves forward who picks a running mate
would pick someone that would be ready
right away to uh
to assume the the governorship and yes
if the lieutenant government for
whatever reason the governor is out of
state if when the governor's out of
state the Senate President and sometimes
goes down to the treasurer becomes the
acting governor
so the
Governor if the governor needed to be
replaced FYI
um the the salary of the governor you
know the person
succeeding the government would accept
this Governor's full salary when Senator
Morse became acting governor for a few
days in 2016. he made a lot of money he
made thousands of dollars uh in those
few days when he was acting Governor so
does that kind of address your question
hopefully somewhat IT addresses the
question maybe not totally my concern
but yeah the question so thanks thank
you
thank you I mean I understand the
concerns that cause you to bring this
forward I
I have some
foreboding or discomfort I I can't I
find it hard to imagine and you can tell
me you know if I'm wrong that
um somebody's going to enter this
position and there's not going to be
pressure over time
to expand the job not just how the
governor uses them but eventually
officially and ends up becoming a whole
segment of government on its own so I
don't know why you would believe that
wouldn't happen and then thus it would
become more expensive and and one point
I would make and that is uh at least for
me I I you can tell me you know why I'd
be wrong but uh I don't think adding
more excitement to New Hampshire
politics is a positive
thank you representative I mean
excitement in a good way
um so yes yes to your point about uh
Mission creep or or growing or uh I
think there's a lot of folks here that
watch watch the governor's office and
what they're up to what they do what
they spend and everything that's what we
do
um and with this 424 or 423 of us who uh
keep an eye on the executive branch and
if if there was and it ended up being
some uh excessive uh spending or
activity
then you know transparency I mean people
are watching and can have some impact on
how the governor does whatever the
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much
representative thank you madam chair
thank you very much Madam chair members
of the committee for the record my name
is Dan McGuire I represent Epsom
and I didn't see anyone else in the
audience who was going to speak against
this so I thought I'd at least come up
and and present some the other side of
the story
um first of all
maybe we don't have to do anything
simply because we're talking about
fixing a very rare circumstance right
the state's been around 250 years
we can't really point to some horrible
thing that's happened along these lines
so you know maybe it's less than ideal
what we have now but it's so rare
that's okay to be less than ideal every
once in a while you know
um but let's say you're convinced you
don't like the current situation and you
want it to be changed
um so let's talk about our governor in
particular and what they do and so on so
New Hampshire has the weakest governor
in the country the only real power that
the governor has on their own is vetoing
legislation
the governor is only elected for two
years many are elected for four
um the governor appoints Commissioners
and appoints a lot of people
but often those Commissioners are given
contracts longer than the governor's
term
right so the commissioner of I don't
know dot or something might have a
five-year term and so the person in that
role could be somebody left over you
know it could be somebody that that's
not going to be appointed by this
Governor at all and and so they don't
necessarily work for the governor in the
same way they would in many states you
get a new governor you clean a house
right you have a whole new new set of
Commissioners and so on okay that's not
the case here we have a lot of
continuity among the Commissioners and
the executives this thing
and then finally we've been thinking
that all we have is a governor but we
really have six elected members of the
executive branch we have an executive
Council right there are five elected
members of the executive Council from
five different regions
and they work closely with the governor
anytime the governor wants to appoint
someone they have to approve it anytime
they want to sign a contract above a
certain amount they have to approve it
right so already the governor's power is
less so certainly the governor doesn't
need help right so the the governor
so it doesn't have a lot to do I guess
is my point and so so the idea that we
need an extra person to help them that's
not really the case but but beyond that
because I'm somewhat sympathetic to the
idea that it's awkward to pick the
Senate President out of the Senate and
have them do something else now that's
not that unusual I mean the the US
government makes the the U.S vice
president the president of the Senate
right so it's not you know mixing the
two is not just never done or something
like that but even so it does seem
awkward right having one less Senator
what do you do re-elect that that
position or who knows but but if you
wanted to fix it to me a better way of
fixing it would be pick an executive
counselor somebody who's already part of
the executive branch somebody who's
already been elected not quite Statewide
but by a very substantial margin and so
just ask the five executive counselors
to promote somebody into that you know
leftover position for a year or or less
you know whatever the the amount is
right it's it's an unusual situation but
but it seems to me that would be an easy
an easy fix and then there would be no
question about mixing the legislature
with the executive branch
um and and be somebody familiar with the
going things that the government
Governor has been working on and so on
you'd still have the argument well what
if the executive council is one party
and the governor is another well
obviously you've got a divided
government right so just that happens so
so overall
um I guess I I don't care for this
approach thank you madam chair okay are
thank you
thank you very much I'm resident Timothy
Horrigan from the Stratford district 10
which is just the town of Durham I'm
used to representing multiple towns so
um I I checked off support with
Amendment and though my thinking and
this is not much different than uh the
other represent the representative who
just spoke and in fact last year I uh
checked off that I was opposed I think
um
and the basic issue behind this I think
probably does deserve to be Revisited
I'm not crazy at all about doing this
New Hampshire way
um I think the New Hampshire way it
usually works but sometimes it doesn't
so I don't think paying someone a token
125 dollars a year to twiddle their
thumbs while waiting for the uh
Governor to die or resign is really uh
it's it's it's a bad idea even if it
doesn't cost anything and I think the
cost would be substantial and I frankly
would think it would be better
to leave that part about the
compensation out in which case you could
be set the same way the governor's
salary is set the Commissioners other
words in the biennial budget process and
although there you do have the question
of what to do with the first lieutenant
governor but actually you'll have time
to put that in the budget because um
the way the time line works for this
particular thing so even
so even if this passes to people
people don't get to vote on it until
November 2024 and the ballots aren't
printed up until after the state Primary
in 2024 so there's a very long
you have a lot of time at your disposal
um so you don't have to pass this uh
there's no point in passing this right
away you definitely will want to keep it
over the summer and retain it because
our some aspects of this transfer of
power is probably should be looked at um
there is right now if the office of
Governor is vacant in the first year of
his or her term we have a special
election although the president the
senate or whoever else is in line serves
as the acting governor
until such time as there's a election
and we might be able I think certainly
might be appropriate to push that uh you
know into the second year too
um at least at some point in the second
year um
what happened the last time we used this
of course uh Senator Morse continue to
be the president of the of the Senate as
well as the governor acting Governor but
that was only for three days and they
Governor the current governor he's still
there Johnson uh Kristen Nunu had
already uh had already been elected and
his elections already been certified he
was just basically waiting for days for
Chris and Nunu to you know be officially
declared the governor and I
I don't specifically remember whether he
sat whether I think president Morse sat
with the senate or whether the president
pro tem filled in for him for those
duties during those few days but the
anyway so I say certainly the so there's
certainly something maybe you might
enjoy looking at and I definitely would
uh say it's a bad idea to have a
lieutenant governor who has no powers at
all and has only paid a token amount I
think sounds I know it doesn't sound
like the New Hampshire way but I think
he should be paid you know an
appropriate salary as determined during
the budget process just like we did with
the governor right now and the
Commissioners and I think even the
executive counselor's salary said the
budget process and
you probably will need a staff we'll
need a car we'll need a desk and a phone
and all that stuff and also you may
want to consider if there's any specific
Duty you want him or her to do while
she's serving as a lieutenant governor
uh most
states in the United States the uh
the vice president or lieutenant
governor Service as the president of the
Senate that might be an idea or one sort
of a joke thing I do which I'm offering
to serve as a joke but I've been
involved a lot with what's left of the
register probate office we might be able
to make a lieutenant governor the
register of pro Statewide register of
probate for all 10 counties but you
probably should give him him or her some
sort of specific duties to do rather
than just sitting at his her desk or
maybe not even at his or her desk just
in the corner of the governor's ante
room twiddling their thumbs just in case
the governor uh suddenly is no longer
there I don't think that's a good idea
so I would
I would say uh definitely need some work
and if you and this may be an
appropriate Bill to retain over the
summer but
not that we don't have other things to
do all summer so thanks a lot if you
have any questions I can answer them
seeing none thank you very much
thank you madam chair and honorable
colleagues it's fun to be back at Edna
I've missed you all
um for those of you returning
um I'm gonna make three quick brief
points
um this again to underline the fact that
this is a bipartisan bill
um the fact that the Civics component
and the engagement component for the
executive branch is a positive thing
the design maybe if I'd written the bill
would be a little different maybe a
little more staff or something but
honestly the approach that the
representative from Loudon wrote it is
very New Hampshire and it's unfair to
compare New Hampshire to other states
given how we do things for example
uh New York state is considering raising
their legislators pay to over a hundred
thousand dollars that has never come up
in this state as any Factor whatsoever
to raise our pay I think it's just fair
to look at the New Hampshire way and I
think that this approach
has no negatives it is pure positive
and I could see a scenario where a
current governor could pick someone as
wise and gravitudinal as the
representative from Loudon imagine
having someone else to assist on
important topics such as veterans issues
who has served in the military I think
that's a great uh
a great option to have
so that's it I hope I kept it to the 30
seconds I promised but I think this is a
great idea and it is a bipartisan bill
with no drawbacks as far as I see it
thank you very much are there any
questions
all right seeing none
is there anyone else who would like to
all right seeing none I will close the
public hearing and thank you all for
and the committee will resume on